l'ailer ont une voix particulière avec
un enracinement d'ailleurs qui a fait la
différence on l'a vu aux élections
locales si le rassemblement national
comme la république en marche on
encaissé une défaite aussi cinglante aux
élections municipales et cantonales
c'est bien parce qu'il n'y avait pas cet
enracinement on a nous des députés qui
ont un enracinement solide et puis par
ailleurs un projet pour les législatives
donc on présentera à l'occasion de ce de
ce conseil national le 7 mai prochain il
n'y a pas de double appartenance
il n'y a pas de double appartenance
c'est à dire qu'on est les républicains
on ne peut pas être les républicains et
majorité présidentielle on ne peut pas
être les républicains et reconquête on
ne peut pas être les les républicains et
et horizons on est les républicains un
groupe indépendant ni la double
appartenance n'existe pas